لقد بدأنا الاستوديو الخاص بنا في عام 2007، وكنا
ندرس سلوك الطيور في ذلك الوقت،
وفكرنا على الفور كم سيكون رائعًا
إذا أخذنا حركة
الطيور هذه ولكن جعلناها ملموسة في السماء
ودمجناها في ما تراه خلفنا،
إذن خلفنا أنت  شاهد ألف
طائرة بدون طيار في محطات الإرساء الخاصة بها، كل
صندوق يحتوي على ست طائرات بدون طيار، يبدو نوعًا ما
مثل طائرتك بدون طيار الأساسية ولكن تم
تطويره خصيصًا لهذا
التطبيق،
اليوم نحن نطير بألف طائرة بدون طيار،
إنه أكبر أداء
قمنا به حتى الآن وكنا كذلك  سعيد جدًا
بالحصول على أول تصريح على الإطلاق في سنترال
بارك للطيران
بطائرات بدون طيار، هذا نظام واحد، يضم آلاف
الطائرات بدون طيار وجميعها متصلة
وبضغطة واحدة على الزر،
تظهر في الهواء
[الموسيقى]،
هدفنا حقًا هو جلب الناس
الكثير من الخلفيات المختلفة واللحظات
المختلفة في حياتهم معًا
في هذه اللحظة وأن الجميع يرتاحون
ويتناغمون مع نفس
التردد، تسمى القطعة الفنية
امتياز الحرية، علينا أن
نفهم أنه في المجتمع يتعين علينا
تقديم التضحيات للعمل معًا
كمجتمع اجتماعي  هيكل إذا نظرت إلى
أسراب الطيور، فإنك تعرف في أذهاننا أن هذا هو
الشكل العضوي الجميل الذي يطير بحرية، ولكن
في الواقع يبدو الأمر حقًا بناءً على
قواعد محددة جدًا بالنسبة لي، وهذا ما
يمثله هذا السرب، إنه هذا
الجسم الجماعي من الأفراد الذين
يعملون كمجموعة  أن تكون
النتيجة الجميلة الأكثر كفاية
لثقافات متعددة وأشخاص مختلفين يجتمعون
معًا ليكونوا أفضل نسخة من
أنفسهم. كان الهدف من هذا العمل
دائمًا هو فتح خيال الناس
لأنه عندما تقوم بشيء ما لأول
مرة فإنك تفاجئ الناس بطريقة
ينسون أين  إنهم يسقطون
كل شيء من حولهم
وينظرون إلى شيء نأمل أن
يفتح أفكارهم حول موضوع العمل